welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and we gotta talk
about the ending of Shazam 2 including
its two post credit scenes that very
well may lay out a potential future for
the DC extended Universe I'm talking
Gods and Monsters baby if you haven't
seen Fury of the Gods yet this is your
spoiler warning whether you take the
whole shazamilee or go solo man you're
gonna have some hearty laughs so don't
spoil yourself hit pause on this video
and come back once you've seen the Wrath
of the daughters of Atlas firsthand if
you want to look like a part of the new
rock star Shazam Ali head on over to
nerdriot.chop to grab some sweet sweet
merch wear it around town wear it to the
movies now on to the video in the
aftermath of shazam's Showdown with
Calypso and her Dragon Laden where Billy
makes a heroic Sacrifice by
supercharging the wizard staff into a
magical A-bomb the shazamoli and The
Wizard choose to bury Billy in the realm
of the Gods A fitting resting place for
a hero with the powers of Solomon
Hercules Atlas Zeus Achilles and Mercury
how they get here is a little vague
considering that all magic has been
drained from the Wizard's staff and
Anthony lost her powers but hey let's
just assume that Laden left an entrance
to the rock of Eternity open as part of
his Rampage or the wizard used a glyph
based access code similar to the one
that Dr Savannah used in the first movie
all I know is that they definitely had
to carry Billy's corpse through a
labyrinth Billy's funeral not only
signifies the death of our hero but more
or less the death of the Divine magic of
the old gods between the Wizards
stealing the powers of the Gods to
emancipate humanity and ares going rogue
to kill all the other gods in the
prologue of the first Wonder Woman the
daughters of Atlas are seemingly the
last of their kind with hespera and
Calypso dead and Anthea and the Wizards
staff depowered all hope for restoring
the realm of the Gods is extinguished
but wait what's that is it a bird a
plane a cameo no it's Wonder Woman if
you're anything like me and you keep
obsessive tabs on every trailer and TV
spot released you probably already knew
that Wonder Woman would appear at the
end of the movie God damn it DC
marketing you can't just say that the
movie is full of surprises and then ruin
the twist ending before it's it's even
released but anyways Wonder Woman as the
sole remaining demigod a daughter of
Zeus restores a spark of magic to the
staff rebooting it and subsequently
returning magic to the realm of the Gods
this surge also revives Billy restores
anthea's powers and puts the staff back
online so the Philly fiascos are able to
return to sort of saving their City
interestingly while Anne decides to
remain in the realm of man to learn from
humanity and flirt with someone who
definitely does not pass the half your
age plus seven rule we do now have an
open plot thread pertaining to the newly
restored Realm of the Gods now here's
where we get to speculate on the murky
future of the dceu this renovated Realm
of the Gods is something we might
actually see again after The Flash movie
reboots the entire DC EU it should be
noted that this reboot reportedly isn't
going to erase everything we've seen
from the last decade of DC movies
instead they're going to pick and choose
which elements they want to bring
forward essentially parts of the new
continuity will mirror or share
continuity with this current one but
we'll have to wait to know the exact
detail Tales James Gunn did say during
his announcement of the upcoming slate
that Shazam 2 perfectly dovetailed into
his vision for the future of the DC
franchise the first chapter of this
Vision coincidentally is called Gods and
Monsters hinting that he wants to lean
into themes of godliness so having a
fresh uninhabited realm of gods teeming
with magic might be the perfect
playground to return to as we move into
the post-credits scenes we're gonna find
more examples of connective tissue that
Shazam has to confirm post-flash DC
projects both Zachary Levi and director
David F Sandberg have said that if this
film is deemed successful then their
Shazam might find a home in the rebooted
DC EU ultimately it's gonna come down to
money but based on the nature of the
post-credits scenes we're about to dive
into it does seem like James Gunn and
Peter Safran want to continue using
Shazam down the road so while I admit
that this realm of a Gods link is
tenuous to guns road map I do think that
it's our first hint that this movie
might play a role in shaping DC's future
thank you to betterhelp for sponsoring
this video movies and TV can be great
escapism but when it's time to face
things head on Better Health is here to
help better help is the world's largest
therapy service and it's a hundred
percent online with better help you can
tap into a network of over 25
000 licensed and experienced therapists
who can help you with a wide range of
issues to get started just answer a few
questions about what you're looking for
from therapy and what your preferences
are better help will then match you with
a therapist from their Network that's
right for you after that talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether it's via text chat phone or
video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge
betterhelp gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you'd expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p dot com slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy so let's check out these
post-credit scenes in the first one we
see two familiar faces appear agents
hardcore and Economist from Peacemaker
these government agents approach Billy
in the woods Nick Fury style to recruit
him for Amanda Waller's Justice Society
of America we just saw the JSA and Black
Adam and Shazam would likely fill the
magic Powerhouse slot left in the wake
of Dr Fate's death he'd likely be
working with Adam Smasher 2 cyclone and
Hawkman if he were to join although
Billy was definitely disappointed to
learn that he wasn't being asked to join
the Justice League because one of James
Gunn's first new upcoming DC projects
will be a TV series about Amanda Waller
called Waller I think it's likely that
we'll see her continue on her quest to
build a super team it says a lot about
Levi's potential future of Shazam as
they've already set up a way to include
him in the upcoming Waller project I
mean James Gunn's wife is showing up
here in a teaser for a project that's
post-universal reset while some may
argue that Black Adam did similar World
building and their Rock isn't returning
this is the first DCU project out under
saffron and Gunn's eyes Black Adam came
out in October and guns started working
officially in December he would have had
to Greenlight this scene's inclusion and
the film could have easily been released
without it side quest we also get a
really interesting tidbit in this scene
regarding Marvel's place within the DC
Universe it turns out the DC heroes
haven't heard of The Avengers as Shazam
pitches The Avengers society as a new
name for the JSA in the MCU however
we've heard DC and its Heroes referenced
a couple of times most notably in the
eternals pastos's son mistakes Icarus
for Superman and another scene refers to
kingo's valet karoon as the Alfred to
his Batman proving that regular people
in the MCU still read DC Comics
traditionally in the comics both
franchises exist within one another as
fictional as they occasionally reference
each other from time to time finally
let's talk about the second post-credits
scene where we finally get a hilarious
follow-up to the post-credits scene from
shazam's 2019 film if you recall the
post-credits scene for that movie showed
Dr Savannah losing his mind and prison
desperately scribbling magic
inscriptions on the walls of his cell
before being approached by a talking
creature promising revenge in power at
the very beginning of the first Shazam
we see Savannah as a child he's chosen
as a potential Champion by the wizard
who ultimately rejects him from the
position for his impure heart but before
he even gets a glimpse of the seven
deadly sins encased in stone Young
Savannah sees a lone centipede trapped
in the terrarium inside the rock of
Eternity that little guy ends up being
Mr mined a venusian worm with mind
control Powers an extremely formidable
Baddie from the DC Comics this little
guy wears a voice translator box but can
also read his victims and allies Minds
with telepathy in the comics Mr mind has
the ability to consume the history of
the universe altering our world and its
events irreparably originally the Shazam
sequel was supposed to feature a team up
between Savannah and Mr Mind against the
samly one version of the script even has
Savannah and Mr Mind as the one who
summoned the gods to the human world but
their plot line was cut to streamline
the pacing and run time of the movie Not
only is this scene in a playful jab that
their last meeting was not going
anywhere but using these two in the
post-credits scene a second time
actually makes a lot of sense for the
future of the dceu if Gunn does decide
to keep Shazam Mr mind is the perfect
character to use for the monster half of
his Gods and Monsters chapter fun fact
Mr mind is the leader of the very first
super villain team in comic book history
the monster Society of evil this
villainous group first appeared all the
way back in 1943's Captain Marvel
Adventures number 22 and featured a
rogue's gallery of villains and monsters
that acted in opposition to Shazam and
the Justice Society of America Gunn
could hypothetically build up his
version of the JSA and reintroduce Mr
Mind as the leader of the opposing MSC
partnered with Savannah we'd have a
seamless way to integrate Shazam back
into the dceu with Gods and Monsters on
the horizon shazam's ending has given us
both a new realm of the Gods for the
dceu to populate as well as a green
little leader capable of banding
together deadly monsters personally I
really think that they're going to
continue this storyline in the future
but obviously I can't promise anything
I'm just a little YouTube Lady gun did
say though that all the projects
currently announced aren't all that he
has planned for his Gods and Monsters
chapter so there's your Ray of Hope
Shazam fans if you want more Shazam like
I do it's up to us to show up to the
theaters and show this franchise some
love after all baby Shazam 2 or as I
like to call it fast and the furious of
the Gods is all about family follow me
on Instagram and Twitter Whitney puppy
follow me rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you